yo what up I'm Nick Cannon and I'm about
to answer the Internet would you rather
have a threesome with two female little
people done it
[Music]
what is the here's this animal you think
you could take in a fight a fairy I've
had fights with ferrets and I'll [ __ ]
them up I got ferrets when I was a kid
and like they used to like my brothers
used to play pranks on me too like like
when that's how you wake up in the
morning they throw the ferrets in your
bed and you just wake up swinging they
fight back because they get on their
hind legs is crazy sorry Peter but I'll
be [ __ ] fair it's up would you rather
sit down with your parents and watch
every sexual encounter you've had or
watch their parents sex tape when they
can see me shower I'm waiting I don't
have a problem while parents watching me
get down would you rather have your mom
read your mind during sex or have your
girlfriend read your mind the rest of
the time again I don't really care what
my mom thinks so I my mom was a teenager
when she had me she was a freak from the
beginning if you could die and come back
as any inanimate object what would it be
a dildo oh man a woman would you rather
have a chick have a chick a great ass
but sideburns or a chick with great tits
but a thin mustache great ass and
sideburns all day all day I've actually
I think I know how you were to ringing I
know her
if you had to eat one human body part
what would it be
vagina do it all the time yeah I don't
care like what what would be the number
one song you want played at your funeral
gigolo hey let are Kelly come sing
attitude
you have to have a devil's threesome
with one male actor who would it be I
don't want to do this at all man if I
had Mickey Mouse Mickey Mouse you can
take down Minnie together let's get to
it would you rather have your porn
search history shared with all of your
Twitter followers of your family I don't
know they're kind of like I don't care
like I watch lots of porn like I'm more
parents know it and I think the people
on Twitter who follow me know it too
I like I'm really like the the
substitute teacher porn in the stepmom
porn those are that's me all day like I
kept being like where you're like you're
like playing a video game and the hot
stepmom comes in like that's me all day
would you rather have a threesome with
two female little people done it Oh what
the 7-foot told you I'll never had
seven-foot tall chick so I would go down
because I did the little people sorry
I'm have done it you have to do it in
internationally internationally its
internet you got its international isn't
Dubai it was one night they were Russian
in Dubai crazy story but they were like
yeah man it was a good night but that
was also the night was like I think I've
gone too far
think I'm gone too far
[Laughter]